se joint à nous maintenant car vice
président de l'association des médecins
microbiologiste-infectiologue du québec
monsieur valls bonjour bonjour très bien
vous voyez les semaines sont très
longues effectivement particulièrement
pour vous de travailler dans le secteur
de la santé bonjour à une question pour
vous l'aurez mais c'est allé de
plusieurs déclarations au cours des
dernières 24 heures il y en a une qui
attiré mon attention particulièrement et
c'est lorsque l'organisation mondiale de
la santé a dit écoutez il est trop tard
actuellement on ne pourra pas endigué le
flou de ce virus s'est répandu ça s'est
répandue trop rapidement et est partout
sur la planète alors entendre ça ça veut
dire écoutez on est pris que ce virus là
jusqu'à la fin des temps est ce que
c'est ça que ça veut dire comment est ce
que vous réagissez vous à cette prise de
position
cette déclaration de m s c'est quand
même il faut le souligner c'est bizarre
que l'eau est mince encore une fois face
au genre de déclarations sachant qu'ils
ont été très lents a vendu à toutes
sortes de pressions politiques pour
déclarer qu'on avait une pandémie à
l'échelle planétaire et que encore
pendants il n'y a pas si longtemps que
ça au mois de février
il nous disait que finalement la
transmission à l'échelle planétaire
risquez de ne pas être si terrible que
ça donc c'est c'est un changement
drastique et les saints montre comment
l'om est des fois réagi à des pressions
politiques plus qu'à autre chose
maintenant au delà de tout ça ce que ça
signifie
c'est tant qu'on n'aura pas un vaccin
efficace qu'on pourra administrer à très
grande échelle à tout le monde sur la
planète et quand je dis à tout le monde
c'est vraiment à tout le monde c'est sûr
que ce virus là est sorti de la boîte et
pouvoir maintenant le contrôler et en
pouvoir limiter sa dissémination est à
toute fin pratique impossible parce
qu'il ya tellement de pays affectés dans
des endroits qui n'ont pas forcément des
ressources médicales pour tout contrôler
alors ça deviendra très difficile de
pouvoir remettre dirait le couvercle sur
la marmite et d'empêcher la transmission
faut quand même souligner qu est des
fois des pays qui sont pas des pays très
développés qui ont pas des moyens
énormes et qui ont très bien réussi à
contrôler le virus puis je voudrais
juste devant vous en peut-être en donner
deux là mais le vietnam par exemple
n'est le maroc qui sont deux pays sans
avoir des ressources immenses enquin
même réussi à très bien contrôler le
virus avec des mesures simples mais très
agressive et je vous dirais une mise en
place très rapide de toutes sortes de
mesures de quarantaine d'isolement de
porc de maths leur traçage des contacts
etc
bon alors si vous nous dites qu'il faut
comprendre c'est un peu à la légère on
peut c'est pas tout noir et c'est pas
tout blanc et beaucoup de guily dans
cette crise là c'est un peu ce que vous
nous dites oui tout à fait et puis
surtout il dirige va rester avec nous il
faut attendre un vaccin mais on va quand
même éventuellement un moment donné
arriver à le contrôler la question c'est
de savoir au bout de combien de temps
est-ce que ça va être une question
d'années que ça va être une culture de
une année deux années plus peut-être y
concernant ce vaccin là le ms qui dit
oui un vaccin mais un vaccin accessible
à tout le monde
autrement c'est un coup d'épée dans
l'eau s'il n'y a que quelques pays
privilégient qui peut éventuellement y
avoir accès oui alors c'est vrai mais là
encore il va se poser d'autres problèmes
c'est que ont même si on a des accents
très efficaces qu'ils ont la capacité de
production mondial des vaccins va pas
arriver à servir toute la population
sept milliards d'habitants sur terre en
temps de quelques mois tombe même dans
les pays riches qui vont avoir aucun
accès aux vaccins rapidement il va
falloir prioriser qui va être vaccinés
en premier
est-ce qu'on va vacciner les
travailleurs de la santé les personnes
âgées les personnes à risque les gens
vont ils sont dans les ch et celle des
drôles les plus jeunes ceux qui
travaillent
les premiers répondants dont vous voyez
la liste est longue après ça il va
falloir décider
oui mais dans certains pays il va
falloir aussi même si on veut vacciner
tout le monde les moyens de
communication de dissémination je prends
l'exemple de pays d'afrique ne sont pas
faciles alors des fois arrivé dans des
petites villes lointaines ça peut être
protecteur ça fait le fait que le virus
ne se rendra pas là mais d'un autre côté
il va falloir arriver à ces populations
et les vacciner sans compter les pays
dans le monde qui sont politiquement
instable ou mener des campagnes de
vaccination
c'est si vous pensez à des pays comme le
yémen ou la syrie je suis pas sûr que la
campagne de vaccination va être
logistiquement facile avant de passer
aux questions des téléspectateurs
j'aimerais vous entendre sur la maladie
de kawasaki qui frappe les enfants avec
des inflammations des éruptions cutanées
il ya eu un décès d'ailleurs en france
un des premiers d
c'est arrêt cardiaque c'est très
inquiétant sur pour les parents entre
autres connectés c'est c'est inquiétant
mais c'est prévisible c'est à dire il
faut quand même penser que les remettre
en perspective la majorité des enfants
puis des adolescents il va leur arriver
pas grand chose et les enfants sont très
peu malade donc oui malheureusement il
ya des syndrome de kawasaki ou qui
ressemble au syndrome de kawasaki src
lit on a établi que c'était lié la
commune ben on semble s'il semble avoir
un lien ce qu'on a trouvé avec la cobi
19 avec le virus de lakovic 19 c'est que
c'est un virus qui semble être très
thrombotique c'est-à-dire qui provoque
la formation de caillots qui provoque de
l'inflammation au niveau des artères la
maladie de kawasaki c'est principalement
une artérite lassant
sans rentrer trop dans les détails ce
une inflammation des artères entre
autres au niveau des artères cardiaques
qui peuvent devenir très problématique
mais on envoie des maladie de kawasaki
ça a été associée à d'autres microbes
alors c'est peu fréquent heureusement la
majorité des enfants l'immense majorité
des enfants n'auront pas de syndrome de
kawasaki et vous savez tout peut arriver
il pourrait faire une infection sévère
avec une bactérie faire un syndrome de
kawasaki noah ça n'a rien à voir avec le
bolide 19 ans puisque ça nous aussi ça
nous dit que c'est un virus qui a des
particularités inflammatoires et qui
provoque des problèmes de si vous voulez
de blocage des artères d'inflammation
des artères
il ne reste pas beaucoup de temps pour
les questions des téléspectateurs elles
sont importantes mais y avait des
questions aussi et que je voulais vous
poser sont tous importants le soleil
première question de richard mille est
le soleil étant un grand générateur de
rayons uv
si on place nos masques à l'extérieur au
grand soleil seront testés release est
d'office par le soleil
la réponse est non voilà c'est ça c'est
tout ça et là on si on veut stériliser
notre masque on le place pas au soleil
ces prix hors caisse ouais ça s'est
compliqué si vous les stériliser remet à
ce qu'elle assure pas quelle masse si
vous avez un masque artisanale entre
guillemets que vous avez fait vous même
la meilleure façon de stériliser ses
deux finalement vous stérilise reparler
de l'avc de l'avertissement à la machine
et ça suffira là et puis vous mettez un
filtre dans les deux parties si vous
avez un masque de procédure
ces matches là sont pas vraiment
réutilisables puis les n 95 ont fait
dans les hôpitaux mais bon c'est c'est
dans des conditions particulières est
discutable
autre question si je prends des anti
ch'ti mines et qu'est ce que je risque
de masquer les symptômes du virus
alors non mais c'est une excellente
question d'ailleurs mes collègues
allergies sto québec que font une
campagne de là à ce sujet là et avec
beaucoup de justesse et deux raisons
parce qu'on rentre dans la saison
d'allergie actuellement donc les gens
commencent à avoir des symptômes et dans
certains cas les symptômes d'allergie
les symptômes de l'acte avec 19 ont un
chevauchement et donc c'est important de
bien prendre ses médicaments pour les
allergies pour être certain qu'elle soit
le mieux contrôlées possible et qu'on
n'ait pas à se dire bon s qui tous il
est ternie parce que ces allergies ou
est-ce qui toussent éternuent parce que
c'est un comique 19 donc oui un certain
chevauchement et d'importance de prendre
ces traitements au maximum dernière
question dr weiss quelques municipalités
ont interdit l'usagé des bancs et tables
de pique nique le long des pistes
cyclables
est ce qu'il ya un réel risque danger de
prendre une pause et de les utiliser
ben moi je vous dirais pratico pratique
c'est il ya peu de temps j'ai la seule
chose parce que surtout si vous êtes
tout seul là si vous arrivez vous prenez
une pause et vous êtes une ou deux
personnes en plus qui venait ensemble il
ya peu de chance qui va vous arriver
quoi que ce soit la seule chose
évidemment c'est la contamination par
indirectes c'est-à-dire supposons que
moi j'ai lakovic 19
je m'assois la table qui fais pas très
attention fut jamais à tous et partout
bien je me touche le nez puis je mouche
et puis là je touchais à table et très
rapidement après je m'en vais puis vous
quelqu'un d'autre arrive touche le les
surfaces puis lui se frotte web se
frotte le nez et à ce moment là il ya
une possibilité de contamination comme
ça mais dr weiss merci beaucoup d'avoir
répondu à nos questions aujourd'hui vous
souhaite un excellent week end on en
sait encore un petit peu plus sur la
coved 19 mai on marche encore dans le
noir et on évite de se casser la figure
à ce moment c'est la réalité
merci beaucoup on en apprend tous les
jours ouais merci à la merci au peuple
et au revoir